how long did you stay with tesla far i
stayed there until 2013. what happened
then oh i got fired there was a car in
hawaii that was all scratched up so an
email came to me from somebody way high
up at tesla and said it's the problem so
this lady had contacted elon and my boss
said i don't care what he says you're
not going hawaii for more than 500 so we
need to take care of this lady she's in
her third year of owning this car and
she still has not been able to drive
because it's so scratched up so we got
approval on an email exchanged for 500
tesla would pay one way of that flight
so we shipped all the chemicals buffer
the polisher everything we needed to
take care of a car my son goes there
before he goes on his honeymoon he fixes
this lady's car she's raving about it
she loves i was just so happy my boss
looks at me and goes you're not going to
live through this what you authorize
this because no i didn't he told hr that
trip was not authorized we got fired for
an unauthorized trip to hawaii so i told
tesla's legal i said look i won't sue
you if you'll go and read my email and
the guy got demoted three times but he
still kept his job so that's how i got
fired to tesla was being lied about it
was cutthroat back there